ces taureaux la faute des libéraux que
j'ai entendu pendant 18 mois et qui me
faisait faire des poussées d'eczéma
quand je les entendais se lever de près
18 mois ce qu'on peut changer de disque
le parti libéral je les ai pas pointer
du doigt et je les fais un par acquis de
conscience mais ils ont changé c'est
toujours facile de pointer des eaux pour
éviter qu'on mette les projecteurs sur
nous mêmes
or tout ça je trouve ça dérangeant
lorsque vous étiez dans les enquêtes
policières vous avez vous même couler un
rapport à ce que vous aviez peur que le
ministre à l'époque sam hamad ne le
laisse de côté
monsieur hamad fait partie de l'équipe
de musulmans y aurait ce que vous avez
confiance par exemple que le prochain
gouvernement un prochain éventuel
gouvernement libéral s'il est élu
majoritaire ou minoritaire va donner
suite aux recommandations de la
commission charbonneau sauf penser que
c'est possible oui ou la réponse est oui
j'ai au jour aucun doute
j'ai toujours beaucoup de difficultés
quand on fait des généralisations tous
les libéraux sont tous des bandits une
haute opinion n'est qu'avec ça j'ai
énormément difficulté quand on fait pas
de nuances qui est des gens qui est fait
des choses de pâques avec des gens du
parti libéral
absolument et encore aujourd'hui je vais
vous répéter sans aucun doute dans mon
esprit
le parti a changé le parti a appris et
je mets aussi tourner des réflecteurs de
l'autre côté parce que la commission
charbonneau son mandat comme en cent
quatre-vingt-seize 2,96 à 2003 il ya
aussi et un gouvernement péquiste qui
est en place et ont déclenché des
élections avant que la commission
charbonneau dévoilent l'ensemble de ses
recommandations de ce témoignage parce
qu'il ya encore des témoignages
à être entendu alors qu'on avait une
possibilité d'aller jusqu'en 2016 avec
le mandat qui nous a été donnée le 4
septembre 2012 pour quoi déclencher des
élections on l'a alors que la commission
charbonneau campeau finisse et ses
travaux et c'est ça qu'on reprochait
monsieur charest à l'époque et en plus
de ça madame marois et son mari ont été
convoqué en commission parlementaire
mais ont déclenché des élections je
savais tout ça ne fait qu'augmenter le
cynisme
surtout que ce parti québécois la en
illinois où pour obliger des élections à
tous les quatre y'a rien absolument rien
qui obligeait de déclenchement des
élections si ce n'est pour des fins
électoralistes
on n'avait pas besoin d'aller en
élections puisque j'aurai compléter mon
mandat malgré les frustrations que je
vivais en commission parlementaire je
peux vous dire soucier d'un différent de
ce que peut être assemblée nationale on
a fait évoluer des choses on a appuyé la
loire parce qu'on nous avait promis un
projet de loi 2 et 3 qui ne sont jamais
venus
on à appuyer des projets sur des mines
moi je pense qu ont collaboré on n'avait
pas besoin d'un homme et fiction vous
êtes persuadé que les informations qu'on
aurait pu apprendre sur le parti
québécois devant la commission
charbonneau aurait pu poser des
problèmes à ce parti absolument qu'est
ce que vous faites croise même des
témoignages qui ont été entendus il ya
des gens qui l'ont éthiquement pourquoi
les témoignages qui sont venus parler de
gens du parti québécois ont été occultés
très rapidement pourquoi même la
première ministre a lancé une certaine
semonce envers la commission charbonneau
en faisant de fait attention quand des
témoins parlent de bien circonscrire les
témoignages elle s'est rétractée le
lendemain
mais non on n'en a pas parlé de ça dont
le gros méchant actuellement c'est le
parti libéral qui a fait des choses
totalement ignoble soit c'est le message
qu'on entend il y en a une partie de ça
sinon je rapport justement déposé le
rapport qu'on a déposé
mais est ce qu'on est capable de changer
de refrain est de dire qu'est ce qu'on y
fait pour bâtir l'avenir